black panther ça nous a transportés tout
le long j'ai adoré le film c'était
génial ça super héros très cool content
d'avoir d'avoir redécouvert ce
personnage puisqu'on avait vu brièvement
bêtes s'étaient gens mais franchement
j'ai kiffé c'était vraiment mais
vraiment les décors son fils d'effets
spéciaux sont très bons la mise en scène
est très belle j'adore plein de
rebondissements c'est un bon fonds
d'actions hk
nous on proposé un nouvel univers qu'on
n'avait pas l'habitude de voir genre
paysage un soutien ou de futurs
visuellement c'est énorme la bande son
elle est trop cool les acteurs dont il
ya une touche d'humour ces archives
illustrent avec les filles il était
juste énorme
je trouvais que la musique était super
bonne aussi
j'ai passé un super moment je pense que
c'est mon bébé préféré super fidélité
aux comics je les trouvais super man
j'ai trouvé super moderne aussi c'était
génial il ya une vraie histoire il ya un
vrai fond avant le message il est bon
exceptionnel magnifique c'est un très
bel hommage à l'afrique c'est un
magnifique février comme on est fans de
marvel et tout ça on était servi
vraiment j'ai pris une claque
non je crois que j'ai pris un coup de
griffe tellement c'était bien j'ai hâte
que le monde entier le voit
[Musique]